almost all of them have already done it.
but I now also times n few parties.
yes and we start right away with what very
sympathetic an.
I think I'll put you on the 3.
and now we have the opposite.
free voters.
i find you right now for the
what you pull in Bavaria
not convincing at all.
ne
the SPD
would have been a party,
I used a few years ago
probably would have rated n bit higher.
but I find the currentmigrationspolitischen course
very problematic.
therefore 5.
yes
CDU,
CSU still a quite problematic party
yes,
which currently prefer to deal with uh
Playing language police stops
than with uh real problems.
because a sensitive language is a cool thing.
but I also remember,
that there are also others
problematic parties are in this filter.
therefore now a very
very badly meant 7 for you.
and there we have the winners party.
very nice
Number 2
huh?
yes and there we have our jumpscare in the morning.
I think you know where you are going
and you know why.
yes and there we have the next
very problematic party.
I am not a fan of personality cult
and I find
Sarah wagenpnecht also always seems like so ne
yes somehow older very bitter person,
who didn't quite understand,
that times also change sometimes.
that's why I think the 9 fits there quite well.
yes,
now only the 4 are left.
Do it this way.